معنا من الرياضه هذه المره زميل عبد
الرحمن العصيمي مراسل صباح العربيه عبد
الرحمن بهذه التقارير الجميله من الجميله
سلطنه عمان حديثنا اكثر عن فكره هذه
السلسله كيف جاءت وكيف كانت تجربتك فيها
نعم صباح الخير مجددا نادين وسهام كنت في
مسقط لتغطيه المؤتمر صحي دولي
وتمددنا الرحله ايام اكثر لمحاوله يعني
ايجاد بعض القصص اذا تذكرون كنا كل يوم
الصباح معكم على الهواء مباشره مره مسود
مطرح مره عن الحلوى البحرينيه مره مع ال-
اا الطباخ العماني فائز الاستاذ والزميل
ومديرنا مدير قناه العربيه والحدث الاستاذ
ممدوح المهيني ارسل لي على الواتساب وقال
لي عبد الرحمن عمان بلد غني ايه يعني مثل
لاي صحفي ايش رايك تقعد اسبوعين زياده او
تعود الى عمان اكثر وتقوم بصناعه التقارير
والسلسله من سلطنه عمان ف- همم هنا جاءت
الفكره وفعلا همم بدانا بهذه السلسله
طيب يعني فعلا عبد الرحمن كانت تقارير جدا
لافته ونحن كثير استمتعنا سواء باللايفات
اللي طلعت فيها وحتى في التقرير انبهرت في
صباح العربيه وفي نشرات الاخبار بس عبد
الرحمن هاي مش الزياره الاولى لك شو اللي
تغير عليك
عمان زرتها اكثر من مره اول مره كانت 2012
وبعدين زرت 2018 بعدين زرتها في اثناء
وفاه همم سلطان قابوس طيب الله ثراه في
بدايه 2020 وزرتها في هذه المره كل مره
ازور سلطنه عمان اشهد تغيرات كبيره على
الصعيد التنموي اولا على صعيد المشاريع
والان مع الحقبه الجديده ومع السلطان هيثم
الذي تولى زمام الحكم قبل تقريبا همم ثلاث
سنوات
عمان دخلت مرحله جديده من تطوير والبناء
المشاريع السياحيه ايضا المختلفه الان همم
دخلت رؤوس اموال جديده واستثمارات مدهشه
وكبيره على مستوى الموانع على مستوى
المنتجعات السياحيه على مستوى ايضا تطوير
البنيه التحتيه في سلطنه عمان فتغيرات
كبيره حتى على المستوى الاجتماعي طبعا
الانسان العماني مختلف دائما نادين وسهام
يعني التعليم لديهم على مستوى عالي
المستوى الصحي ايضا عالي جدا الانسان
العماني متسامح للغايه مع جميع الطوائف
والمذاهب والاديان
ولا يهتم بعرقك او لونك وهذا حقيقه ملفت
للغايه ويشد الانتباه مباشره الايزائر او
سائح يزور سلطنه عمان العمانيين محبين
للحياه محبين الموسيقى محبين الفنون محبي
ايضا للمهن اليدويه والحرف لديهم تاريخ
وعراقه
ملفته للنظر وايضا عمان دائما حريصه على
ان تفتح ابوابها للجميع كل مره ازور عمان
اشاهد شيء جديد ولاحق تغيير كبير على
مستوى الاقتصاد والسياحه والتنميه
طبعا عبد الرحمن كليب خاص قام باعداد فريق
تصوير تغطيه سلطنه عمان لخلف الكواليس
مفاجاه خاصه لكواليس الزميل عبد الرحمن
العصيمي نتابعهم معانا
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير
كيف الحال
في هذا السوق فعاليات متنوعه لجذب الزوار
تستطيع من خلال هذا المكان
جميل جدا مين نواف صح
انت عارف يا وليد هذا المحراب يعني انا
ماذا انا افضل صحفي مره على تاريخ الصحافه
العربي تاسيما من امام ميناء
[موسيقى]
انت عامل انت عامل مشكله عندنا لو سمحت
يا بهاء والنبي يا بهاء انا اسف
[موسيقى]
تفضل تعال تعال
[تصفيق]
مع ساعات الفجر الاولى يتوافق التجار من
خلال هذا الباب الى هذا السوق
خلال هذا الباب الى
[موسيقى]
ايش رايك مفاجاتنا يا عبد الرحمن
انا كان معي في الرحله هذه زميلين زميل
بهاء الدين الجزار وهو مثير ومخرج ومونتاج
وكان معي زميل وليد الهويشل وهو مصور معنا
مكتب السعوديه هم قالوا لي في مفاجاه لك
بس والله ما يعني ما كنت ادري انه ههه
بتحكي لغه ممتازه بس مش لهلا مش قادره
اعرف شو هي هذه اللغه
ههه
والله عده لغاتي اول شيء يعني همم
لغه البلبله
ما هو مشكله احيانا تكوني مجهزه انت عارفه
يا نادين اشتغلتوا ميدان فانتي مجهزه
وقاعده في الميدان وتشتغلي والشمس وحر
وبرد يعني مهما كان الجو
احيانا باشياء سياره جايه وراك همم حيوان
مره من جنبك انسان يكلم بالجوال خلفك يبغى
يرسل الرساله لاهله مثلا يعني
اثناء التصوير بعض يطلع على الهواء وبعض
يطلع ما يطلع لكن مهنه المتاعب هي لكن
المتاعب اللذيذه اسميها انا يعني عندما
اشاهد همم تفاعل الناس وحبهم لهذه القصص
الواحد ينسى التعب كله
العاملين في الميدان يعني العمل في
الميدان هو العمل الاساسي الذي يثقل شخصيه
الانسان المهنيه شكرا لك وكل عام وانت
بالف خير عبد الرحمن